- I have a daughter who's three,
and by the time she's having kids,
I want the world to be
completely different for her.
- So, should we go?
Yay, let's go.
Whoo.
So many moms go through a postnatal mood
or anxiety disorder alone
and don't know where to turn
and don't know where to look for help.
And they know something's wrong,
but they just lack the resources.
- When you're going through
postpartum depression,
that's one of the most
isolating experiences
that you can have.
And I think, knowing that other people
are going through it with you
is so incredibly important
to being able to just keep breathing
and get out of bed everyday.
- It wasn't until I
started talking about it
and just having people I barely knew say,
"Oh yeah, I had that."
And then being able to
talk, that I just realized
I wasn't crazy, that I
hadn't done anything wrong.
Unless you've walked
through that darkness,
you just don't get it.
- This is so common.
They say one in seven moms go through this
but you wouldn't know it.
And we talk about
motherhood and giving birth
as if it's this wonderful
joyous thing, and it is.
But it can be very, very
difficult for a lot of moms.
- My recovery didn't start
until I met other moms
who were going through
and had been through
the same experience as me.
So every year, this is a great opportunity
for other moms to come to a place
where they're gonna find their community
and have that moment of recovery
that I was so lucky to have.
- [Voiceover] It's worth
it to get through it
and connect with other people.
- There's nothing more important
than knowing that you
are not the only person
going through this.
- It takes a team.
We need every mother who has ever had
maternal mental illness and every person
who has ever loved someone
with a maternal mental illness
to join our team.
If we don't all come together,
we'll never be able to get to the day
when every mom knows what's wrong,
knows where to go, gets help quickly,
and recovers quickly.
If you are listening to this right now,
and you are a mom who is struggling,
please know that you are
loved and understood.
We know how you feel.
We know all the doubts that
you have about yourself.
We know what it's like to feel
like you are a failure as a mother,
worried that you'll never get better.
We're also fortunate to have come out
on the other side, so we know that you can
and will get through this.
And we want you to know we will be here
for you all along the way.